[Musique]
bonsoir tous nos petits amis
waouh quel silence nicolas et
pimprenelle ont l'air très calme ce soir
je me demande ce qu'ils fabriquent ils
sont sûrement dans la cuisine en train
de faire de proue cateau je peux y aller
dit patron wind & north mais ne soit pas
trop gourmand est patron je sais me to
d'ignorance société où on les chaînes tu
crois qu'ils vanessa réveillon je suis
chaque année nous adorent la soupe des
ligues tient un jour tu encore une carte
là et puis tu es trois roues le bon ben
c'est bien ce que je pensais
ils sont dans la cuisine le jury ou
menez votre vie on est en train de
préparer quelque chose de très très bons
au bugue tous quelque chose d'être qu'il
a de truculents aux dites moi il a fait
une bonne soupe de légumes 9h et toi tu
vas tu que tu qu'a coûté
[Musique]
votre f à la hachette walla walla non
merci beaucoup
tiens tiens ta serviette pas si nicolas
sayeh ont comme tu es bono nonce et
voilà le mot nude le curieux c'est sous
écoute la nonne oms
elle est formidable qui a un peu de ciel
est un tout petit peu de points tu veux
encore du poireau no no no mercy avec
eux c'est très gentil de m'avoir fait de
l'asu seul mot je parle waro
il paraît que ça fait grandir tu sais le
nonce oui et puis ça donne bonne mine
mais puisque je vous dis qu'on ne peut
pas le web ne nous tu vois je t'assure
que nous n'aurions rien qu'un tout petit
peu ne fait pas le bt non je ne mangerai
pas non vg pas l'appeler vient pas le
poids en qui j'ai une hausse est très
vite et de faire des caprices
tu devrais avoir honte maintenance reste
quoi nous nous nous on va se coucher de
celle d'un grand bien des grenelles bien
la prochaine fois je la mange mais ses
bras me promit me vous la ferez cuire
vos amours c'est promis paul une annonce
tu viens pas preneur
pas nuit des noces bonne nuit gauche
peut avoir un
[Musique]
hautmont
oh
[Musique]
où
j'espère que vous n'avez pas fait comme
nounours et que vous avez bien manger
votre sous ce soir te voilà gros coquin
tu sais que si tu ne manges pas tu as où
tu ne viendras plus voir tout est petit
ami au patron vous verrez compte sur moi
je le ferai plus de caprice c'est bien
un nounours on verra alors en route
bonne nuit des enfants
à demain
bonne nuit
[Musique]